[Music]
in false alarm news we all my bad
alright submitted by Rebecca a hey
Hawaii and then Japan have both sent out
accidental missile alerts to its citizen
Japan Thais heard about this one of our
friends that we know posted it on who
Kelly Slater yeah I thought Kelly Slater
posted the post in Japan or in the
Hawaii Hawaii I know about the whole
thing but not the Japan thing yeah so
Hawaii they sent out an alert that
looked like this
emergency alert ballistic missile threat
inbound to Hawaii seek immediate shelter
this is not a drill that's like an Amber
Alert yeah no yeah it's a push
notification on every if this shows up
on the freeways and the signs and all
that stuff
oh wait what the [ __ ] do i androids get
that yeah of course we matter to
androids lives matter not offended
reports saying like certain Android
users reported that they never got it oh
that's cuz they got a Samsung Galaxy S
to be there that their network just
sucks okay cuz I know some people's
networks they don't update them all yeah
why don't they figure out why how can
what Amber Alerts come out I get it like
three days later see there you go the
kids already said he has an iPhone yeah
it's a network yes this is the initial
message and then 38 minutes later 38
minutes old man that's when they sent
the second alert saying there is no
mecha threat or a danger to the state of
Hawaii a repeat puzzle why did it take
so long
dude it's you gotta read it in the
pigeon accent though first read the
warning in a pidgin accent like you're
about to freak out dunno you gotta do
the pigeon access I'll do de Vaca do ha
brah
but let's dig missile threat bro and
back to Hawaii seek immediate shelter
pack your bags and surfboard bronzer
bacon oh yeah man what's the one
supposed to call me that
oh just kidding bro there's no missile
threat or danger
imagine all the board shorts that are
being packed and flying out of the door
I wonder if they teach you like missile
drills like what it says take shelter
yeah what are you supposed to do high
under a coconut tree a lot of people
were like what shelter we don't know of
anywhere to go like we haven't been
trained like prepared for this so I'm
going to show you guys a video clip of a
compilation of people freaking out and
like they're recording their last words
that's so funny
you're on vacation it's a beautiful
tropical paradise you're in your bikini
I think the part that makes it more sad
is that it's happened before
yeah I Pro Harbor so yeah those damn
Japs I knew it's like there's a reason
why they have those warnings it's
because it's happened to them so they
probably have like PTSD like oh [ __ ] I
remember this happened to us my uncle
saw the the Pearl Harbor yeah you say
you saw the Japanese did he get that
message there's no cell phones at the
time no recently anyone get it no no he
lives here now California oh yeah there
was a report of a man I got a heart
attack while eating a spam musubi oh I
know what'll happen to me but I know
there's people who care about me that
just want to know that I love you guys
somber words Oh Hawaii after a false
alert went out on TV the US Pacific
Command has detected cellphone oh my god
reading ballistic law inbound to Hawaii
seek immediate shelter
this is not a drill 4:38 terrifying
minutes many people believe the alert
was real that's the Hawaii version
already muscle brought panic parents put
their children in manholes in closets
when I saw the things say this is not a
drill that is the impact line right
there yeah
you are not Hawaiian was it um it like
all the Hawaiian Islands maybe yeah
that's a good question I'm not I'm not
too sure the did they she's been
reporting Hawaii why do you ask
just worried you know whose job is
really important that guy in the school
who was saying that should over the
intercom cuz that's not how I would have
said it he was like very calm because
this is not an other get boom dude it
was a missile
I don't think hiding under in the sewer
is gonna help yeah I think that might be
worse yeah I don't even know that's
gonna blurt no I jump on a [ __ ] boat
and say go yeah I always get killed by
tsunami instead did you go see the
interview of the old Japanese man cuz it
was someone that was under him that
[ __ ] up I hit the button oh yeah yeah
and he was like I'm gonna talk to him
today but yeah he's like this although
Japanese man he's pretty much saying
like you usually you know like the
supervisor they cover for them they're
like you know what ultimately I'm the
leadership as my father goes nope it's
his fault menu so this person was in
training and so you were supposed to
click apparently this is what it looks
like this is what was selected this is
what should have been selected and now
they have oh now it says false alarm on
it like this can never happen again
why don't they just have a separate
program for ya for training
that's not very smooth the learner
carves they got two steering wheels
right they may need two steering wheels
for this type of stuff too so this is
like the updated version of what their
programs look like now but initially
they were saying that it was a drop-down
menu and that instead of putting like
the like bit of false alarm one
yeah they're putting this actually this
is the problem because everybody tries
to be all smart and scientific is [ __ ]
if this button was just written out
shit's going down for real nobody would
have ever touched blue it looks too much
like a Craigslist ad I don't like that
yeah yeah all that government should is
hella janky the DMV website all this
other [ __ ] any better graphics if
they made that link red no one would
touch it yes imagine thirty-eight
minutes and what would you have done
what kind of crack me up so yes it was
very sad but what crack me up is the
scene that Channel Nine's trying to show
you everyone in Hawaii is like like
scattering everywhere for shelter there
wasn't that many people in my opinion
there wasn't that many people but the
people that they did show they were
running but then you were like I was the
slowest [ __ ] Hawaii Britney I'd get
in my car so [ __ ] driving I assume
that during this there would be like
thousands of people running it was like
30 people just I mean were they gonna go
yeah to the ocean if a bomb was gonna
blow up LA oh we're done yeah I'm just
like dude so much traffic I don't know
what I'm gonna go well where do we go
damn especially in LA all the freeways
are gonna be like I would just start
running red lights and I would just go
as fast as I can
there's probably all these cars just
stuck because everyone's trying to leave
at the same time well where do you leave
- I don't know over the mountain it's
like look go how come we can't just you
know just be happy man just y'all do
you're out there we have about to build
and I pretty much
my tripod which others should learn
classic it's really your people that are
trying to my people yeah you need to
talk to your North Korean friends we
split a while ago all right
I don't know uniting for the Olympics
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh really for real I
would say I will say I will say this I
don't mind the citizens of North Korea
because they're suffering right but
those are my people even though I don't
stand what the [ __ ] you're saying cuz
you're Korean is straight up outdated as
[ __ ] those are my people right there
however the military and the evil man
that looks like me I don't like him yeah
so Japan also sent out oh my oh yeah
yeah but this one's not that bad cuz
they they ended up sending the the fact
that it was a false alarm quickly after
like less than 10 minutes it was not
that bad but still and those like first
you must go to log it has to be like 30
seconds for sure is it the same person I
know it's the same in turn have to go to
my backup job it was a human error as
well but all they say is that the
broadcaster blames a switching error
they don't elaborate we don't know what
that means
it's a switching error war makes me sad
yeah and missiles make me sad yeah but
that's the reality we live in right now
ever since this whole like North Korea
stuff has been happening and then we
hear like oh they're potentially gonna
hit Guam and stuff I'm like dude la
would be like the prime target for
mainland the whole code what is the main
reason that North Korea hates everybody
well that's their tactic to stay
separated from everything really no it's
it's basically that's how they get a lot
of aid it's like false extortion and
it's also for them to keep power in
their own area
they're not gonna everyone knows they're
not gonna do it it's just a threat
tactic isn't the the effect of them
threatening to bomb everything the fact
that they are getting their resources
cut off like isn't it perfect right no
so they're they're kind of like saying
we're gonna do something so give us rice
and maybe we'll stop the nuclear program
cuz like the end game for them is
terrible because if they do that that
whole country will be obliterated you
don't right they don't want war that
would be even worse that you don't have
the resources they don't want that they
just want to always be at the cusp of
like oh we're threat guys just remember
just remember you know that's just their
way of town that's their style of
politics in the world that like they
played that game but it also keeps
people at bay so that no one's gonna
invade them and no one's gonna Punk them
I hope so because my peoples are their
southern Queens no North Korean people
they're still Korean people the citizens
are still there's people yeah yeah so
they died they're just a casualty of war
that [ __ ] sucks yeah I hope that no
war happens at all and then I mean they
just keep trying to be like like a
barking Chihuahua if they're if they
stay a barking Chihuahua and they do
this for the next 100 years or so it's
like it isn't it's not gonna do anything
it just kind of scares people from here
to there but the war is what's dangerous
[Music]